NASIR KAHN: Hello and welcome
to another episode of Google
Wallet Developers Live.
We're going to talk about
Instant Buy today.
We have had previous sessions
on Instant Buy.
This is another session.
My name is Nasir Kahn.
I'm a developer advocate with
Google Wallet team.
And I have with me Nagesh
Susarta, who is a developer
programs engineer on our team.
We also have a partner
from Tagstand.
His name is Joshua Krohn,
joining us on Google Hangout.
Hi, Josh.
JOSHUA KROHN: Hi, guys.
NASIR KAHN: So as I said,
Tagstand is one of our Instant
Buy partners.
And in this show, we're going
to talk about the app that
they have developed
with Instant Buy.
So, Josh, let me just start
with you first.
I know that you have
a few apps.
Tell us what Tagstand
does and what have
you been doing recently.
JOSHUA KROHN: So we're working
on developing software that
allows your device to use its
knowledge of where it is and
what you're doing, respond to
its current context, and do
things like change settings
or perform actions on your
behalf, rather than requiring
the user to take out their
device and interact with
it to perform all of
these routine tasks.
NASIR KAHN: OK, nice.
And I know that you
have a few apps.
We have one app called NFC Task
Launcher, with which we
have the Instant Buy
integration.
So, Nagesh, I think you
had a plan to show
the demo to our viewers.
NAGESH SUSARTA: So I'm bringing
up the NFC Task
Launcher here.
It has a few tabs.
If you can see, there's Buy
tags, obviously-- but that's
the first thing you
want to do--
My Tasks, and Examples, which
has a custom list of tasks.
So the first thing you want to
do with the NFC Task Launcher,
if you don't have the tags,
is to buy them.
And this is where the Instant
Buy integration comes in.
And let's say I like the
black NFC tags here.
So I can actually program
them once I have them.
NASIR KAHN: So let
me ask this.
What is an NFC tag?
What are we buying
here with this?
NAGESH SUSARTA: So what an NFC
tag is is that it's actually a
small tag, which can be
programmed by using the NFC
Task Launcher.
NASIR KAHN: OK.
NAGESH SUSARTA: It can be
programmed to do a set of
tasks, which can vary from
starting Wi-Fi, stopping
Wi-Fi, launching an application,
starting media.
And I'll show you an
example of that.
NASIR KAHN: OK.
NAGESH SUSARTA: I mean
through the demo.
But first, let me
buy the tags.
NASIR KAHN: Excellent.
NAGESH SUSARTA: And so they have
integrated Instant Buy.
So I click on it, and it shows
me my masked wallet
information, which is exactly
which card I want to use for
this transaction.
I say, OK, I want to use
this particular card.
And then I go through the
flow, and it shows me my
masked wallet information, my
shipping address, in case I
wanted to change it.
There is an ability for
me to change it.
And it also shows me the
card I've chosen.
I have the ability to even
change that option right now.
NASIR KAHN: So, Nagesh, when you
did that, and you clicked
on the Buy with Google button,
is that when you were
interacting with the
Google Wallet APIs?
NAGESH SUSARTA: Yes.
NASIR KAHN: And you're getting
the card, or the masked card
at least, and the shipping
information.
NAGESH SUSARTA: Yeah, the
first step is to get the
masked information.
And then once you have the
masked information, typically
you would show it to the user.
And Josh has done a great job
by showing it to the user.
And then when the user is ready,
like when I'm now ready
to buy the tags, I confirm
the order.
And this is where I'm actually
getting the virtual proxy
card, which is sent to
my payment network.
So I confirm the order, and then
I get a particular proxy
card and the CVV associated
with it.
And I send it back.
I mean, Josh sends it back to
his servers and completes the
transaction.
Now since I've already completed
my transaction and I
selected super fast delivery,
I already have
the tags with me.
I mean, Josh, I should say
you guys have an awesome
fulfillment going on there.
But I mean, jokes aside, I
already bought the tags
because I'm a fan of NFC tags.
And what I'm going to show
you is an example tag.
Now, since I like listening to
music in my car, what I did
was I built a small little task
list that launches the
Play Music application.
Now this is an app that I'm
already subscribed to.
I'm already subscribed
to Google Play Music.
You can replace it with any
other app that also provides
music in this case.
And then the second task is to
actually start media playback.
So once I created this task, I
can go ahead and get ready to
write this on a particular
tag.
So once it's written
that's it.
That's what it takes to actually
write on a tag.
Now once I've done this,
I take this,
stick it in my car--
I mean, on the central console
or something like that.
And when I just get into my car,
I tap my NFC and there
comes my play list.
And you know that
I'm listening to
Maroon Five right now.
That's how easy it is to
integrate NFC Task Launcher
and the NFC tags, which
are very useful.
Now that aside, coming back
to the actual Instant Buy
integration, I should ask Josh,
how was the integration
from your side?
JOSHUA KROHN: So from our side,
the integration was
pretty easy.
We saw two main benefits
from our side.
One was the reduction
in complexity for
payments for the users.
And the other was the ability to
get some information about
the users, so we could really
tailor the checkout
experience for them.
Previously, we'd been using
Google Wallet because--
or I'm sorry, Google Checkout.
Because we know no one likes to
enter billing information,
shipping information, and
card information.
But there were some real
limitations with that.
The Instant Buy API removed
those limitations.
So now once the user clicks
Purchase, they
select their card.
They select their address.
We have all of that
information.
We can then call back out to
our servers and dynamically
get them the best shipping
rates, any current promotions
we have, like free shipping
for some items.
And we can give them effectively
the lowest price
possible very easily.
And then from the user end, as
soon as they hit Buy, we're
able to process that payment,
send that order directly to
fulfillment, and it's processed
right away.
So we don't have to worry about
queueing up orders and
sending them nightly.
It's very easy.
To do that, we had to do the
integration in the app, as
well as build the back-end
system itself.
NASIR KAHN: Now would you
elaborate on the back-end?
So when you said back-end, did
you have to create some
fulfillment of your own?
Is that what you did?
JOSHUA KROHN: We had to create
an order management system.
We had to write the actual
payment processing, which
we've worked with Braintree
to do that.
And then we had to work with our
fulfiller to create an API
to push orders to
them directly.
NASIR KAHN: OK
JOSHUA KROHN: We had one
developer doing that.
And all of those tests
were completed in
less than one week.
And so even creating from the
ground up, it wasn't this huge
upscale effort that
we had to do.
NASIR KAHN: OK.
Now If there is a merchant who
already has a back-end payment
processor set up, and they have
some kind of fulfillment
in place already, integrating
just the Google
Wallet Instant Buy API--
that piece alone is that--
how long did it take
you to do that?
JOSHUA KROHN: That part of
it took us about a day.
NASIR KAHN: Oh, OK.
JOSHUA KROHN: Instant Buy APIs
are very modular and worked
really well with our checkout
outflow, the way we have the
items set up.
It was really simple
to integrate.
The sample code was very good.
It demonstrated the actual flow,
the logic flow, in cases
to handle very well.
So very easy for us
in retrospect.
NASIR KAHN: And for the benefit
of our viewers who are
interested in getting more
detail about Instant Buy, we
have had previous shows in
which we have gone into
details of the flow--
masked wallet and full
wallet as you
heard Nagesh talk about.
We have much more details there
So feel free to go ahead
and check out those videos
to get more detail.
But while we have you here Josh,
could you would show us
a little bit of a code snippet
or something that our viewers
would be interested in looking
at to see how the integration
actually looks like?
JOSHUA KROHN: Yeah, sure.
So here is, this is the fragment
that displays after
the item is loaded.
So you see the images and the
item description and the Buy
Now button.
So this extends a base
WalletFragment that handles
making the connection to the
Wallet client, disconnecting,
handles some basic error cases,
resolving errors,
things like that.
And that was really useful
to reuse as we go
through this process.
Because it makes the individual
fragments and
activity through [? the flow ?]
much easier.
So you can see here that when
this loads, immediately we
check for pre-authorization.
We ensure that we have a Wallet
request ready, to get
that masked wallet
from the user.
And [? you can see ?]
we're using the item itself,
getting the price, and then
padding it a little bit.
And then right away
we make a call to
load the masked wallet.
And this is done so that as soon
as the user clicks the
Buy button, they're either
presented with the chooser
dialogue, or they go right to
the confirmation, if it loads
successfully the first time.
There's no waiting.
And that's what we
really liked.
It's a very quick experience.
So in that fragment itself, we
have to deal with some changes
in the masked wallet possibly.
So if it's successful, we check
to see if we're ready to
go, effectively, if the user
has clicked Buy or not.
If we are, we launch right into
the confirmation page.
And all that data is ready
for us to use.
If not, we store the connection
result for later
and just wait.
NASIR KAHN: You wait for the
user to click on the button
and then you resolve the
connection result.
JOSHUA KROHN: So as soon as
I hit Buy, we have this
convenient method, Buy
with Google Wallet.
NASIR KAHN: Um-hum.
JOSHUA KROHN: We'll
check to make sure
Wallet's not disabled.
If they have the Wallet
previously loaded, we go right
into the confirmation page.
And then if there's any
outstanding issue, we don't
have a valid connection result,
or Wallet is connected
but we don't have a masked
wallet, we dropped back into a
shared method to resolve
unsuccessful connections.
And that's going to fall back
into that MaskedWalletLoaded
method, so that as soon as we
get a valid result, they're
immediately sent to
the confirmation.
So it's all very easy.
NAGESH SUSARTA: Yeah, perfect.
NASIR KAHN: Very nice.
JOSHUA KROHN: So here is the
actual confirmation screen
that gets displayed.
And again, we're extending the
same Wallet fragments.
You don't have to worry about
managing the connection, for
start or pause or anything
like that.
And all we have to do is
onCreate, we're going to pull
the masked wallet out of the
intent that we sent.
This is a async task that we set
up that's going to go get
shipping data for the user,
based on their country, their
localities, their state--
or if they're foreign,
other locality--
and return all valid shipping
options for that item
specifically.
So we can give them their
rate-based shipping and only
give them only relevant
cheap options.
NASIR KAHN: Very nice.
JOSHUA KROHN: So at this point,
as Nagesh showed, you
can change your payment
method.
You can change your address.
So we have to listen
for these changes.
So when you click that button,
we call changeMaskedWallet.
And then we handle
these results.
When that comes back, we'll get
it, pull the wallet out of
the intent, and repopulate
the data on the screen.
I've taken that out because
there's a lot of code there.
NASIR KAHN: Yeah, yeah.
JOSHUA KROHN: So then that's
all we have to do.
At that point, once we get that
masked wallet back, it
dynamically populates
everything for us.
And we're just waiting
for the user to
confirm their purchase.
Once they hit Confirm, we make
a call to getFullWallet.
We show them a loading
dialogue while it
does that and wait.
But when we call getFullWallet,
we're just
going to grab their state and
country again from the masked
wallet, so that we can get
shipping and taxes, so we can
calculate an accurate total.
We're going to use the
createFullWallet method that
we have to create that
request and load it.
So at that point, all
we do is wait.
And once we get a successful
result, we can make a call out
to process the payment or handle
any incoming errors.
And again, it all calls
back into itself.
So if they have to reload the
full wallet for any reason,
it'll call back
onFullWalletLoaded.
We'll get the success, and then
it'll hit the process
payment again.
Processing the payment is as
easy as grabbing the full
wallet, pulling the
info out here.
You can see some of the
info in here that
we're pulling out.
At that point, we build a
simple name-value pair
document and post that payment
out to our servers.
So you see here's our simple
async task that takes in that
list of params.
We're going to use HTTPPost to
post that out, receive the
result that we get back
from Braintree--
that's our payment processor--
and then the subsequent order
processing on our end, set the
transaction status based on that
response, and then send
it up to notify Google Wallet
what the status was, and then
alert the user.
So you'll see here there's a
utility method in the Wallet
client to post back
to Google Wallet.
We send the transaction ID and
the status we got back from
our server.
And then we start the
OrderCompleteActivity to show
the user either their order
data, or if there was an
error, we push the
error to there.
And that's the whole flow.
NASIR KAHN: Very nice.
JOSHUA KROHN: Their order's
been placed.
It's in our system.
And it's already been dispatched
to our fulfillment
at that point.
So they should get an
email very quickly.
And it will be fulfilled same
business day usually.
NASIR KAHN: This is awesome.
This is awesome.
So, Josh, you just walked
through the entire Instant Buy
flow in what, about five
minutes or so?
NAGESH SUSARTA: Yeah.
NASIR KAHN: That's
pretty much it.
So this is--
NAGESH SUSARTA: You've condensed
it very, very---
NASIR KAHN: Nicely.
NAGESH SUSARTA: And I should
ask you this question.
Which other APIs in Google Play
services are you using?
Because I saw a task, which was
like create a Geofence.
And I was very excited
to use it.
And I would love to know what
other APIs are you using from
Google Play Services.
JOSHUA KROHN: We really like
Google Play Services, because
it lets us use new APIs on all
the devices we target.
We target from API
level 10 and up.
And I think Google Play Services
goes back to API
level eight.
So effectively every one of our
users can use all of the
new features that
gets introduced.
So at this point, we are
using Google+ sign-in.
We use that for cloud backups
and restores.
And we're looking at it
enhancing that pretty soon to
add +1 support and shared
app activities.
We're also using the new
location-based APIs--
the Fused Location Provider that
was demo'ed at I/O this
year, the Activity Recognition
client, and then the Geofences
themselves.
The Geofences is something
that's been really popular
with people, because it lets
them go hands off.
NAGESH SUSARTA: So what can
I do with it exactly?
Can you give an example?
JOSHUA KROHN: Yeah.
So we let you select a location,
either via search or
selecting it on the map, and
then define a radius for that,
obviously, to create
your fence.
Then you can set your conditions
so that when you go
into or leave that place, a
defined series of actions is
run for you.
So you can use it to say, when
you get to work, you can make
sure Wi-Fi's on.
Maybe you're using Bluetooth
in your car.
You can turn it off.
And you can send a text to your
wife to let her know you
got there safely.
NAGESH SUSARTA: Nice.
JOSHUA KROHN: These things
all happen automatically.
And that's something that we're
really excited about.
And we use quite a bit.
And we've got a lot of really
good feedback from users on.
NASIR KAHN: Fantastic.
All right, great.
Thank you so much, Josh.
Thanks for a nice demo and
walk through of the code.
For our viewers, I would
recommend them to go ahead and
check the NFC Task Launcher
app from Play.
Play around with it and
see how it looks.
If you are a developer or a
merchant who is selling
physical goods or services
on Android, then this
is the API for you.
I would recommend
you go to a URL,
getInstantBuy.withgoogle.com.
One more time,
It's actually an
interest form.
This is a closed beta as yet.
So just fill out this form and
somebody from Google will get
in touch with you.
And you can start
out from there.
And you might as well have an
app, just like Josh's app.
And we'll be more than happy
to show it to our viewers.
Thank you so much for
listening to us.
NAGESH SUSARTA: Thank you.
NASIR KAHN: Bye.
NAGESH SUSARTA: Bye.